we're going to be talking about
information theory
and a specific concept called shannon
entropy named after
claude shannon he was a great computer
scientist right there at the beginning
of the field but today we're going to
talk about his most important
contribution which is information theory
so a lot of concepts in computer science
are
directly derived from this more general
theoretic concept
things like
compression zip files
network error correction codes or error
detection posts things like that are all
directly related to information theory
now the simplest experiment that you can
do that involves probability
is flipping a coin
so i have a penny here and i'm going to
flip it and i'm going to ask you to make
a prediction is it going to be heads or
tails people say tails never fails but
i'm going for heads just for two heads
all right
i'm gonna have a quick peek here now if
i told you it was heads how surprised
would you be a bit
just one bit one bit one bit that's
that's exactly right one bit and you are
now one bit surprised it is heads
um
so what if instead i'm going to flip
two coins right and i'm going to flip
them in order to let them land here but
i'll ask you to make a prediction um the
coin on the left will be heads or tails
i'll go heads for that one head and the
one on the right let's be crazy and say
tails tails okay coin one
and coin two
oh is that our tails i can't actually
wear that
so they're both tails oh
how surprised would you have been
if your prediction was completely right
a bit a bit more that's right one bit
more um so obviously there's a
relationship between coin flips and bits
i kind of gave it away
but let's
talk a little bit
about the mathematics behind it so
obviously the larger a probability
is
the less surprised you are by the
outcome
and the smaller a probability is the
more surprised you would be
if the outcome happens
um
and
yeah you see that on lottery winners
faces you see that on
well it's a good thing you brought it up
so we'll talk about the lottery in one
minute so let's come up with a sort of
reasonable formula to to express the
amount of surprise that you have with a
certain outcome so the symbol that is
used for that is the capital letter i
the i stands for
information but we'll talk about why
that is later
for now it means surprisal
and the surprisal of some event e
is equal to
the logarithm
of
one over
the probability
that e
happens so why do we take one over the
probability of e
well because we're saying the less
likely it is the more surprised we are
right so a one in a million thing
surprises us quite a bit more than a one
in two thing so whatever is below the
divisor is what we're interested in so
that's why we're taking the inverse why
do we take the logarithm so the
logarithm
is a function which has diminishing
returns so if we're looking at the
probability as an odds thing so one in
two is an odd of two one in ten is odds
of ten right the smaller the probability
gets
the larger the odds get
but the idea is that if you double the
odds
you only increase the logarithm by one
so you want this diminishing return of
surprisal and that's why we use the
logarithm so every time you halve the
probability you only increase the amount
you're surprised by by literally a bit
otherwise if you got to a million you
would be yeah off the scale right it
would go off the scale way too quickly
so that's why we're taking the logarithm
um so one in a million and one in two
million are sort of comparable in the
amount
that it would surprise us so this
formula makes sense for
coin flips and what we can do of course
is we can plug in
the numbers so let's do exactly that
so
the event here that we have was
um
heads if i'm not mistaken
for a single coin flip so we're talking
about the information content of a
single coin flip being heads which is
equal to the logarithm of one over the
probability now what is the probability
the probability is a half and this in
other words is just
log of two in computer science contrary
to mathematics when we write down the
logarithm we usually mean the logarithm
base two so you can put a little
two here but when we omit it in computer
science we mean two if we want to have
the natural logarithm we would write
something else a base 10 logarithm we
would put a little 10 there if there's
nothing there log 2. so the log 2 of 2
is of course
1
and the quantity the unit is bit
so it's one bit of surprisal and
similarly if we plug in the double coin
flip your prediction if i'm not mistaken
was heads and tails yeah and the
probability of that being right is of
course one in four so we get a logarithm
of
1 over
0.25
which is of course
log
four
which is two bits
so you're one bit surprised
versus two bits surprised this works
nicely for coin flips because all
outcomes are sort of equally likely but
what happens in the case that not all
events are equally likely so you have an
unbiased coin
they're equally likely you have a biased
coin they're different let's take an
extreme example of um
of a biased
event
winning the lottery right there's a tiny
tiny tiny tiny chance
that you win the jackpot
and there is a very big chance that you
don't win the jetpod keep it simple
let's say that there's a one in billion
chance you win the jackpot and when i
say a billion i of course mean two to
the power 30 which is roughly a billion
as most computer scientists will know so
we have two events you either win the
lottery or you don't now if you win the
lottery you'd be
very very surprised right so let's plug
that in i'd be extremely surprised since
i've not bought a ticket in i don't know
how long so
i don't think it changes the probability
that much does it
so let's call the event winning w
so that is
log
1 over 1 over 2 to the power 30 so 2 to
the power
minus
30 and this is of course equal to log 2
to the power 30 which is 30 bits
so if it happens you'd be extremely
surprised but if it doesn't happen
you're not surprised at all right so the
probability of not winning so losing
is
log
1 over and then we get well a tiny
number let's just write it as 1 minus
2 to the power minus 30
and that is roughly
zero point
zero
zero
zero
zero zero zero
zero zero zero
1
3
4 bits so
i think it's safe to say you wouldn't be
surprised even
a single bit so what does this really
mean
what
is more surprising on average flipping a
coin
where both events are not very
surprising or the lottery where we have
one very surprising result
and one
completely unsurprising result
and this is the core idea of information
theory so this is how a notion called
entropy is defined it uses the letter h
and what you do
is you take the event so let's say p for
postcode lottery because we've used the
l for
losing
pretty much the same thing to be honest
we take the probability of the event
which is a tiny probability and that's
the probability that you win and if you
win
you're 30 bit surprised if you lose
which happens
the rest of the time
so that is 1 minus
1 over
2 to the power 13 you're basically not
surprised at all so this tiny quantity
in bits and this gives you the expected
amount
of surprisal and as you can imagine this
formula basically simplifies to a tiny
number right because this number will be
tiny
this number will be tiny the sum of two
tiny numbers is a tiny number so
actually the most surprised we can get
with a
event that only has two outcomes is
actually flipping a coin which is one
bit surprisal
as soon as you introduce a bias
the amount of surprisal goes down let's
link this back to computer science the
notion of information theory right
so what i'm claiming is that what we're
computing here
is what information is
um
if i want to tell you the result of a
coin flip what is the best way i can do
it
uh
zero one zero or one so we need one bit
to give you the result of a coin flip if
i want to give you the outcome of a
single lottery i'm still going to have
to use one bit a zero for losing and a
one for winning
however it says here that we need fewer
than one bits what does that mean well
let's say that you play the lottery for
a whole year and i want to communicate
to you the results over the whole year
what i could do
is i agree with you that if i send you
zero for the whole year
it means you've lost every single time
and if you did win one of them in the
unlikely event that that happens i'll do
a one
followed by an integer
that is the first time you won the
lottery that year and then
repeating that coding in case that
there's another win
even less likely right
so there's a tiny tiny chance that we'll
use more than one bit
and
a very big chance that we use exactly
one bit so on average we're going to use
about 1 in 365 bits per day now that is
still a bigger number than this but what
this is saying is that if you do this
experiment infinitely often
and you come up with the smartest best
scheme that you can possibly come up
with you're still going to have to use
at least
this many bids
per
lottery you can never do better than
this
on average is what it's saying this is
like the absolute
optimized to its absolute kind of yeah
exactly and you can imagine that this is
something that computer scientists are
very interested in because if you want
to
compress a file and you know
how much entropy there is in that type
of file you know you cannot on average
do better than a certain amount you can
stop searching once you found it same
thing with error correction codes if you
know
the throughput in bits of a channel
so an electrical wire you know that
there's no smart way of putting more
information through it than whatever
that number is and that's why
information theory is so important for
computer science
there's the crystal it's vibrating but
only just you know where it is it's not
moving
high entropy is when the probabilities
are smeared out you don't know where it
is so by the time you get a gap it's
easier to find what the factorization is
and then once you've factored it you can
just do these steps to completely
calculate the private key